bon alors on a demandé aux gens ce
qu'ils pensaient de toi dans la rue mais
c'est pas terrible
c'était mon quartier c'était j'ai repris
du terrain à montbard ben voila je suis
très calme puis je suis sorti en ester
on va regarder
comédienne vous intéresse ou pas
pourquoi c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment hors circuit nom qui se
maintient à un peu comme elle peut mais
bon j'ai pas d'antipathie particulière
pour elle mais ils sympathisent physique
vous en vous la trouvez comment
bof c'est pas un fusil que j'apprécie
beaucoup
elle est plus côté à la revue trois des
douze elle est allée voir sa prochaine
pièce d'exceet physiquement pas du tout
loin de là
la trouvez comment je pense qu'elle est
plus longue course rapide intuitif lent
j'aimerais bien partir du 1er là je peux
pas croire que j'en dise ça toi n'ont
fait qu'ils sont bourrés mon avis je
sais pas il ya anguille sous roche
as tu crois tu penses que c'est de
l'intox je pense que c'est un très petit
mais chante on connaît
on va voir alors on va voir sur qui
portait la question et pensez-vous de
line renaud l'une renault monsieur que
pensez vous de lire notamment que
pensez-vous de line renaud
on applaudit
penser que des fois non plus parlé au
début mais ça m'a rassuré quand même
gratuit c'est que dans cette émission on
a une coutume qui est de demander à des
gens dans la rue ce qu'ils pensent de
notre invité est ce que tu es prêt à
supporter ça j'en avais envie à tout
entendre le pire mais je crois pas que
ça soit le pays a good bien
d'un grand bonhomme pour vous oui c'est
quelqu'un que j'apprécie énormément
chose qu'il a des tas de bonnes idées
il est très sensible on va te manquer
des gens comme lui si vous le trouvez
supérieurement intelligent honnêtement
oui je trouve que j'admire énormément il
est extrêmement intelligent et voyez que
son oeuvre restera appelé a sûrement sur
mon but je pense que ça reste après très
bien s'il y avait des centaines de gens
comme lui en politique ce sera vraiment
vous pouvez très intelligent assez web
pour moi c'est un super mec trouve
intelligent oui brillant oui je pense
est intéressante pour vous je trouve
plutôt une manière de faire qui me
paraît intéressant ici relativement bien
décrit un homme qui restera au lit
certainement d'ailleurs il est je crois
classée numéro un parmi les
personnalités mondiales notamment
attardé sur d'autres continents
notamment aux états unis
vous pouvez qui passe bien la télévision
va il passe d'une façon originale à sa
manière
oui qui décrit bien vous admirer tout de
même certainement
il voit pas
mais tenu à calmer un peu a raté
l'académie parce que tu as dit au moment
où tu allais peut-être est rentré tu as
fait une publicité pour vespa en disant
tu ferais rentrée le mauvaise passe dans
le dictionnaire
mais là ce soir est ce que finalement
c'est pas mieux que l'académie ben oui
c'est évident mais si j'entre à
l'économie ça ne surprendra personne
je suis je voulais entre l'académie pour
faire plaisir à mon vieux père mon père
et marc dont la lente une raison d'y
entrer est ce que à ton avis de qui
parle et légendes qu'on vient de voir
je me suis posé devant jozy peut-être à
l'autre on va voir de qui parlez alors
son oeuvre restera appelé à ce monde
sûrement oui je pense que ça restera oui
oui c'est de qui on parle là mnt jacques
yves cousteau dans le jean edern hallier
non non non
par le bien des gens et dernier l'un
n'en est pas question
vous le trouvez brillant oui par le bien
des gens et d'un allié ah non donc vous
pensez que jean edern hallier d'un homme
qui restera non nous parlions plus tôt
pas le talent d'un grand bonhomme pour
vous
jean-edern hallier pardon jean-edern
hallier est un grand bonhomme pour vous
donc plié vous parlez de qui là madame
va vous parler du commandant cousteau je
vous parle de gens et dans l'allier vous
en pensez quoi
alliez passer pour celui qui a quitté
haïti qui se bat là l'enfant côté de
vous à moi je trouve que la france est
une poubelle et qu'on reçoit n'importe
qui n'importe quoi
avec des bidons alors là là c'est un
sketch formidable match absolument
triomphant en vidéo les complimente a
toujours l'appui en jean edern faut le
savoir vous promet d'être pas vous vexer
non seulement je me cache mais alors on
regarde le costard de stars
monsieur que pensez-vous de philippe
bouvard je n'aime pas beaucoup
à votre avis vieux croûtons c'est parce
qu'il est petit qu'il est agressif
j'en sais rien il n'est pas agressif la
taille n'a rien à voir là dedans ou
vieux débris les personnes petit ne sont
pas forcément agressive du tout pas du
tout a dit plus elles sont pas du tout
agressif pas forcément comme les autres
comme les grandes
nous avons trouvé agressif connard
vocabulaire un peu mais c'est pas grave
il est bouvard j'en ai pensé beaucoup de
choses et puis plus grand chose j'sais
pas pourquoi je sais pas j'ai regardé
quelques voix je trouve que c'est un
humour d'accord mais pas de grandes
volées à votre habit à votre habit
vieille peau c'est parce qu'il est petit
qu'il est agressif au alors s'envoler
une question très importante
il bougeait pas la journée non plus un
pardon dépêchez vous de répondre oui je
pas messieurs que pensez-vous de
philippe bouvard du mal du mal beaucoup
de mal pourquoi ces longs sera long à
dire penser que c'est parce qu'il est
petit qu'il est agressif âge avait
jamais pensé qu'il était petit savais
pas qu'il était petit fait plausible
qu'il répond j'ai pas que ça à [ __ ]
non plus il est petit vous allez vous
faire [ __ ]
votre avis via morue c'est parce qu'il
est petit qu'il est agressif
non ça n'a rien à voir avec ma rue c'est
pour lui c'est pour moi c'est pas vous
oh merci on sait que c'est parce qu'il
est petit il est agressif grand con oui
je pensais
bah oui je pense mais bah ouais là la
preuve combat facile
connard ouais vous pensez que les petits
sont forcément agressive connard non
abruti est-ce que tu attachent de
l'importance à ce que les gens pensent
de toi se répand qui pensent quoi -
toujours tiennent mal de gens qui
peuvent penser ce qu'ils veulent
entacher mais les gens que j'aime bien
ça m'apporte que bon on va boire parce
que bien entendu tu t'en doutes on est
allé avec une caméra dans la rue on leur
a demandé ce qu'ils pensaient de toi
mais avant de leur demander ce qu'ils
pensent et toi le rabbit 2 3 trucs très
objectif treize costard de stars c'est
de l'info
on
un spécial je crois qu'il est très
mauvais caractère bon vous êtes au
courant que dans ce métier il a une sale
réputation c'est on peut le dire une
ordure type pas sympa un type odieux
vous y avez carrément ça vous étonne ou
pas du tout c'est ce qu'on en dit comme
je ne connais pas je sais pas si c'est
vrai ou pas ben pour moi c'est pas leur
dire vous promettra pour moi c'est une
ordure vient de découvrir qu'il touche
le chômage sous 19 identités différentes
boshoku pas beaucoup mais monsieur que
pensez-vous de gérard jugnot lui sympa
vient de découvrir qu'il touchait le
chômage sous 29 identités différentes
vous en pensez quoi
29 mois par mois
ouais bah c'est scandaleux c'est tout
non non tout ça ressemble au personnage
chaque mois ils touchent le chômage ce
59 identités différentes
je pensais ce contenu
cent dix-sept fois le chômage on sait de
source sûre que lors de ses dernières
vacances en espagne il a abandonné son
chien en l'attachant un arbre ça vous
choque ou pas si ça c'est pas vrai ça
vous choque vous qu'il ait violé son
chien je suis pas au courant
si c'est vrai c'est dégueulasse mais je
sais pourquoi je peux vous dire accuser
sans preuve clairement je dirais ça
dépend ce dépend de cette façon ça
dépend pour quoi il a fait 6 à un crime
passionnel ou pastis et par un crime
passionnel
c'est pour avoir la maison plutôt
essayer de vous violez vous vous diriez
quoi je refusais enfin je le mot viol
c'est une atteinte à une personne
maintenant mais a perdu jugnot en plus
c'est pas mon genre de types variés vous
faire violer par quel genre de mec
blonde yeux bleus elle montre
pascal
le gars est un nouveau grand nouveau
grand du nouveau rire sérieux mais les
gens dans la rue je sais pas s'ils sont
encore tous convaincus là je me doute
que tu vois venir le roulage devenir
comme c'est ma fille qui pose la
question je demande si c'est bien
sérieux bon va voir laurent baffie
castard le star
une guerre une guerre carrément vulgaire
ça vous choque son côté pétomane p
thomas louis aussi oui oui vous le
trouvez comment vent à ces hideuses il
m'amuse mais dans le mauvais sens
retrouvez grossier ou vulgaires il est
grossier il est vulgaire il est
ambitieux il est pas à sa place je n'ai
qu'une hâte c'est qui disparaît je
trouve ça triste ouille ça fait hurler
de rire des millions de français à moi
je jure que par sa série en fait oui
retrouver grossier ou vulgaires je
trouve grossier plus qu'un vulgaire
ça vous fait rire ça me fait rire il ya
des limites mais oui vous êtes très pipi
caca vous même oui chaussée pipi caca
une belle saloperie parce qu'il prend
les gens pour des imbéciles ne vous fait
pas rien non pas du tout fait rire
vulgaire grossier
les dicastères départ longue date fils
ali ben non j'ai beaucoup aimé ce qui
est dit le deuxième chien mais rien même
les chaises n'a pas aimé du tout dit
dans ces marais c'est grave ça fait que
c'est dû à ces émissions qui a fait sur
tf1 mais je sais pas je me rends pas
compte je suis consterné jean-marie
n'arrête pas de métier tout de suite à
mon avis il ya un truc avant il ya dray
j'espère at on agit de qui parles ces
gens là voilà tu rends compte en plus il
est pas beau ne pas être moi je vois pas
mon pauvre jean marie si c'était toi
dont on parlait vas-y allez-y dit le
moins des bombes à regarder mais là on
va regarder la réponse est la propre
petit téléviseur la réponse est là le
qui parle et on qu'est ce que je pense
de michel chassang
oui jean louis péries rouiba bon comics
pour vous ac on sait vous madame de
michel charasse je préfère me taire mais
c'est vous fait rire il m'amuse mais
allumant vie change j'ai pensé vous
arrêter vous voilà que pensez vous de
michel charasse j'ai pas très envie de
répondre c'est très ennuyeux ou parce
qu'il vous fait rien
oui me fait sourire en fait monsieur que
pensez vous de michel charasse
pour moi c'est une belle saloperie plus
tôt
plus tôt
elle parle pas on parle pas de plus tôt
là on parle de michel charasse migaud
star de 46 quel soutien des gens je vais
te dire ne trouva pas un petit reportage
dans la rue et les gens ted et je suis
sûr que ça te ferait plaisir de savoir
que les gens dans la rue était de tout
coeur avec toi dans ton ses seins par là
tu vas voir
voici costard de stars
maintenant trois quatre ans cela dit
c'est très dur et on va l'encourager à
une parachutée on a besoin de
témoignages d'anciens alcooliques dit
que vous buviez énormément et qui est
maintenant c'est complètement arrêté de
boire et elle n'avait jamais rechute et
pour l'encourager à ne pas rechuter
d'accord dire ça parce qu'on a besoin
des gens et personnes venues lui dire
quoi non non vous mettrez un cache sur
les yeux non non écouter excusez moi
mais je suis pas alcoolique vois pas
pourquoi je veux raconter des choses
comme ça pour une émission le fou je
veux dire je tourne monsieur vous avez
arrêté le voir depuis combien d'années
est pas arrêté de boire je n'ai jamais
vu j'ai quand même une belle tranche de
pochtrons monsieur au montage on coupera
on dira vous êtes alcoolique
combien de litres de vin par jour à 3
litres et demi j'avais encore des
séquelles aujourd'hui un petit peu et un
petit peu je tiens encore de je tremble
un peu d'accord des fautes de goût
immonde genre écharpe verte sur terre et
bleue
oui encore fort pas content pas content
du tout vous dites parfois c'est dur je
suis tenté de boire un petit coup dur et
parfois c'est dur je suis tenté ça
m'arrive de temps en temps pour faire la
scène là où il allait j'ai gueulé dans
le coin pour montrer les fléau de
l'alcoolisme
allez y messieurs
images terribles qui je l'espère
aideront ge à cannes plus jamais boire
une goutte d'alcool
effectivement deux ans deux ans et ce
sont les alcooliques anonymes qui m'ont
aidé les amis m'ont pas aidé la
littérature m'a pas aidé baudelaire ne
va pas aider puisqu'il dit il faut
toujours être ivre de vin de poésie ou
de vertu ball un bout de l'air doit
lancer le poète j'ai plus de souvenirs
charles baudelaire la littérature
française mon dieu quel conseil
donneriez-vous à jacques dutronc pour
qu'il arrête définitivement de bois
avant qu'il ne refuse jamais de penser
qu'il est jacques dutronc qui l'a
sûrement déjà fait des choses difficiles
moi j'ai pas vu son van gogh qui pensent
à van gogh van gogh les draps on va
faire la scène de la rechute vous faites
semblant devoir
voilà les choses en ont fait semblant
voilà l'image d'une rechute terrible et
oui il en met partout c'est pathétique
ouais laurent baffie
on imagine maintenant tu sois là assis
et qui est des gens dans la rue qui te
pose toutes les questions qu'ils veulent
et imagine que ce soit laurent baffie le
reporter tu es très affirmatif il tue
près voici coster de stars
il est là sur le plateau ils vous
regardent vous avez une question à
l'opposé eux non son prost 6 icifer
prochain qu'en dire à nos la pierre à
quelque chose un prochain spectacle
alors oui pierre jeu il vient de faire
l'olympia et non attends c'est pas
déroger des récents jeux tu as forcément
a subi toute ta carrière s'il a mal pris
trouver notre question la suisse est
bonne chance et je prends pas des
mongoliens pierre je pense que je trouve
alors soit pas celle non plus trouvé une
question intelligente j'ai pas de
questions à lui poser je suis désolé
pour la peta ok alors moi j'ai rien à
lui dire vu que ma soeur c'est une
[ __ ] a rien à lui dire pourquoi ya
pas plus originales
ils font semble beaucoup trop
l'influencent de jolis attendait il me
répond non c'est pas une [ __ ]
jedermann questions à me poser un peu ça
peux pas te perds toujours pierre une
question mais je prie la [ __ ] va
sortir du champ monsieur ben voila merci
bon j'ai pas je vois pas ce que je
pourrais lui poser comme question
s'appelle détonne poème dit chez moi
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est un mot
sexuelles non il est en larmes vous avez
gagné bravo
ok merci messieurs les temps laruns je
sais pas je savais pas plus posé ceux
qui trouvent ces conneries hier en
écoutant des blaireaux comme vous une
idée bien jouer les garçons je me
demande où liessies seul trop attendait
parce qu'elle me parle dans le casque la
non pierre c'est pas une vieille [ __ ]
wallemme ne connaît pas tout le monde
n'est pas obligé non parce que vous le
connaissez pas alors excusez moi n'ont
soit pas aux dieux pierre je veux dire
madame te connais pas c'est tout
rigolade
c'est incorrect ce que vous dites là je
ne connais pas la personne en question
c'est à vous croire tout va bien madame
le mal pris c'est pas très correct de ta
part alors mal à me poser une question
là je pose pas de question et les gens
qui sont incorrectes permet pas à soi
disant monsieur check point commun la
qui se permettent de dire qu'à 80 en est
une [ __ ] c'est honteux
d'accord avec vous il me dit vous dire
qu'il n'a pas dit [ __ ] noms et
adresses que jeudi il a dit il n'a pas
dit [ __ ] il a dit vieille [ __ ] et
pamiers
avec vous trouvez jeanne moreau lance
même un pareil à lui même il est
toujours sympathique
joue très bien
elle est formidable quelle est la scène
que vous avez préféré tout en général je
peux pas est ce que c'est vous a choqué
la scène d'amour entre le moine
trappiste et l'iguane chiant je m'étais
beaucoup de monde et lorsque le shérif
et l'amour au chef abyei est un symbole
pour vous
oui oui bien sûr lequel il ya
l'amour une attirance mutuelle vous avez
pleuré à la fin du film lorsque bambi
des lance amer aux allemands il ya
toujours une petite émotion quelle est
la meilleure scène de film à votre avis
la meilleure bas vers le début quand une
fille d'un couple dont n'importe quoi
qu'elle est on reprend quelle est la
meilleure scène du film à votre avis la
meilleure scène du film toy lembras quel
est à votre avis la plus belle scène du
film
au début quand on voit qu'ils marchent
quand le troupeau d'éléphants rentrer
dans sacré coeur sur la musique du
dernier et 47 our lives de georgette
lemaire ça vous a plu cette scène
ouais mais je trouve ce sont des
situations extrêmement improbable et
quelle est la casquette que vous avez
préféré la cascade la cascade
quand il se jette du vide mais il se
jette dans le vide ça a été un crève les
séquences la séquence c'est quand ça
dans le vers la fin quand ici avec la
voiture
c'est un film en costumes d'époque ya
pas de voiture non mais attendez qu est
ce que vous racontez c'est pour me
vanter des conneries c'est que la peur
mais je n'ai pas vu outils
alors pourquoi vous en parler ce n'est
pas lui c'est insensé votre comportement
qu'est ce que je vous ai dit mais c'est
insensé ça vraiment les gens veulent
parler de tout sans jamais rien la voir
vraiment
on
et la valise en carton sa mère mais non
ici c'est sa mère lina les souza et la
mère de ne-yo vous saviez pas c'est va
reprendre le spectacle de sa mère la
valise en carton où j'aimerais le voir
sa mère les portugais mais les chanteuse
portugaise je suis portugaise alors ça
tu avais un traitement quelque chose
qu'aucun traitement dépilatoire sa mère
qu'elle sa mère de l'enseignant donna
summer
sa mère raconte le spectacle de sa mère
la valise en carton visant à le voir vu
que c'est une portugaise doit avoir du
poil aux pattes c'est très bien géré la
voir parce que moi aussi j'en ai voir
mais là j'en ai pu parce que je suis
pile et vous adorez sa mère linda de
suza elle a maigri de 5 kg une journée à
l'on sache bien sûr absolument écrasés
sous les voies
il répondit seconds ont fait la scène
finale bon il vous attend depuis deux
heures vous courez vers l'autre et vous
vous retrouvez enfin la fin du film on
vous a jamais vu comme ça ça nous évite
nous de payer une comédienne l'agencé la
scène finale qui la collecte et à
picoler encore attention quand je
direction vous courez au ralenti action
c'est bon le mouvement pour la scène du
baiser final sur la bouche on leur fait
une dernière fois les i action action
et là vous sortez la langue un peu verra
pas les bactéries à la passion sortez la
langue encore là l'ont regardé la caméra
change un peu la donne un petit peu vous
trichez vous trichez genre vous trichez
mademoiselle boussole voilà mettez-vous
menton contre le menton ne vous
rapprochez pas aller si oui si j'en vois
la tob bras c'est comme ça
oh
je
la figure il c'est une petite scène
kaeppelin grande importance pour la
compréhension du film c'est très
important il attend son fils depuis deux
heures et vous vous arrivez evo10
instant l'acte arrive c'est au hockey
moteur action
alors ces affaires là que tu arrives il
va pas c'est pas de ma faute non pas
trop picolé et celle là c'est ta faute
le texte action alors c'est assez relax
arrive c'est pas de ma faute
céret ont fait la claque tout seul
jusque là jack pas de texte au corps ne
riez pas ne riez pas ne riez pas encore
la version 10 la scène ben je sais pas
ouais j'ai senti c'est bien mais c'est
jean carmet genre voulait faire on a
besoin d'un figurant pour la scène
finale du film
maintenant ça s'appelle j'en ai ras le
béret donc justement cherché quelqu'un
qui est un béret comme au hockey pour
payer oui un cachet à monsieur sera
caché l'aspirine vous allez en prendre
plein la tronche
vous devez ce qu'ils veulent à l'esquivé
pas oui méritait clara plex sinon on va
vraiment vous bourrer la gueule action
voilà pas claquer la dernière année la
dernière vite parce que l'afo
contournant la scène du viol avec
monsieur vite ça nous donne de quoi
vous cherchez quoi madame le concert de
renault non non il passe ici fontaine
saint michel
c'est la mère qui prend quatre ans
la mère elle m'a pris
même souvient un martin
voilà un mec se classer ses passes les
mix de tétouan devoir ouais bah là je
suis venu parce que
et j'ai l'impression qu'il a changé
beaucoup ça fait de la peine de le voir
un creux de la vague aujourd'hui tout
marron beaucoup savaient vraiment chichi
giron les boues parce que [ __ ] j'en ai
pleuré c'est trop après super parce que
c'est trop fort mais si tu penses que
bruel lui a piqué un peu tous ses fans
t'as fait ça s'est passé selon java com
- comme les jo sont son cours a coûté ce
sont ce genre de musique il sa pétition
s'en foutent bruel croit pas en ses pas
le dernier album il en a vendu 8
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
76 c'est que moi j'ai un chien et sa
fouille lâchement pour le vérifier j'ai
seulement j'ai mis ce foulard est pour
toi à toi tout petit ouais h toujours au
tce parce que parce qu'il n'a plus voulu
dit parce qu'il est un travail que vous
l'aimez beaucoup et que vous allez
acheter son prochain album sais pas trop
je suis toujours pas convaincu que vous
êtes le vrai chanter un peu pour voir
qu'est ce que vous les joues sont à vous
de choisir ce alors là c'est pas l'homme
qui prend la mer
c'est la mère qui prend là ça vous
rappelle quelque chose
vous avez une petite place pour lui et
ben je vais pas de porte monnaie pour
moi avec une carte bleue et pontault je
suis très content de vous rencontrer
moi je suis un fayot tu peux lui dire tu
1 c'est plus qu'une mère maintenant mais
au nom oui il y en a on se demande si
j'attends passé ou en étrangers
voulaient bien signer sa pétition contre
le réchauffement de la planète alors au
venir la maison un jour suisse et
beaucoup dormi ça marche pas du tout son
album il allait faire une tournée dans
le métro ou les lignes modèle
autographes les crimes chanson sur ton
temps ça n'a pas marché
dépêche on essaie d'avoir au moins trois
d'autographes aujourd'hui avec dutroux
et vous le faites travailler dur comme
ça tout le temps
s'il reprend les compères et sont trop
il y aurait 50 millions
le prétendant
qu'est ce qu'un des stars
la leaf est aujourd'hui contre la télé
poubelle sauf quoi de voir manifester
comme ça évidemment ça fait plaisir de
voir patrick seale voici que je vois
qu'un télévision je vois pas dans le
vide comme en connaissent et les raisons
de son départ donc manifeste contre les
émissions les nouvelles émissions qui se
qualifie de télé-poubelle genre perdu de
vue et au train oui je pense qu'ils
doivent horizon puisque au lieu de
soutenir monsieur ghosn et patrick est
un monsieur qui est très peiné de mon
départ à tf1 merci mais j'espère que ça
se passera bien pour vous vous avez
quand même un contre un message de
soutien va peu de sébastien
qu'est ce que je lui dis si vous
souhaitez qu'il reste à la télé dit tu
es qua non j'essaie de black c'est cool
tu feras de la place pour rock'n'roll au
fait de voir partir le tf 1 ça me fait
de la peine
il devrait pas parce qu'elles sont
molles ces émissions sont très agréables
à voir
il ya de bons acteurs et limites surtout
très bien il offense une imitation
pardon et qui vous fascine et mutations
au pas au mode normal alors ma
chaussette
quel talent la raison pour laquelle il
est
c'est pas moi c'est toutes ces émissions
d'aujourd'hui quoi maintenant moi je
peux plus continuer comme ça quoi il
faut je passe à autre chose parce que je
mets morts pourtant dans cette basse
quand vous êtes quand même quelques mois
non aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'une merde
hein ça fait d'apple le pacte quitte tf1
merci merci c'est sympa merci tout
réfléchi et orgue l'audiovisuel attend
dé lui c'est pas un intellectuel c'est
un animateur et l'a pas compris deux
mots de tout ce que vous devez dire
son rôle est ce c'est de faire semblant
de reconnaître les caricatures
d'intellectuels commencer celle les
nerfs quand les lui simplement je ne
parle jamais simplement je parle aux
oiseaux et j'ai par le cor courbin ne
trouvez pas qu'il ait enfin sa juste
place
peut-être je sais pas c'est pas moi de
juger je ne regarde pas beaucoup la télé
dont vous dirait de rafah remet le
couvert de la médiocrité avec moi non
c'est tentant ouais bah ouais mais il
faut taper sur les gens comme ça dans
une poubelle on les sort de la poubelle
moi je n'ai d'yeux
télé poubelle en vue de thé merde
c'est
dans celle ci on compte 200 habitants
voient temps tu auras ça quand tu auras
dugourd [ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est bien
ça fait tout on peut tous passé il faut
arrêter avec la télé poubelle je suis
pas j'ai pas si on les attend ce qui est
dramatique c'est que tu es à la télé
mais l'expression tellement drôle tu as
un avis tu as un avis sur un truc tu dis
vrai pardon monsieur je pense que tout
de suite ça tire de partout on applaudit
laurent d'appui encore une fois est-ce
qu'ils montrent des enfants
bien sûr ça mon bien des enfants aussi
bien que moi un moment très très bien
oui tu vas voir cela la honda fit
j'ai fait l'école des fans ouais j'ai
fait l'école des femmes dévié quel âge
j'avais à l'époque j'avais 5 ans
habitait c'était dave ça s'est passé à
l'émission elle-même ça s'est bien passé
mais bon pour passer à l'émission
jacques martin était un peu spéciale qu
avec les enfants leur demander des trucs
un peu bizarres
vous avez demandé des choses bizarres à
bout à l'époque ouais ouais par exemple
bas genre d attouchements des choses
comme ça quoi
carrément [ __ ] peut-on parler ce genre
de choses c'est tellement traumatisante
que quelque part
et si les toits pas se voit aujourd'hui
vous lui diriez quoi [ __ ] je veux dire
espèce de gros dégueulasse et je lui
mettrais une énorme gifle et je lui
dirai qu'il ya beaucoup bouleversé ma
vie en fait campagne de diffamation
contre chaque matin on a besoin de
témoignages vous dites que vous avez
participé à l'école des fans et vous
aviez cinq ans et d'essayer vous violez
il essayé de vous violez hockey
attention va tourner
mademoiselle vous avez fait l'école des
fans vous aviez quel âge où j'avais 5
ans et je chantais très bien à l'époque
s'est très mal passé je crois savoir
effectivement très mal passé jacques
martin m'a violée je soutiens que
m'avait il dit
il est ouvert la brèche si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi car depuis ou êtes fait
tiré par foucault et sabatier sébastien
sébastien aussi pas mal de jeux vidéo
je te remercie pour tout ce que tu as
fait pour moi est bon mais ça va quoi je
me suis remise quand même de mes
émotions nous a jamais remise
voici de nombreuses victimes des enfants
qui sort du casting de jacques martin et
qui se sont tous fait plus ou moins
violet ils ont tous été victimes
d'attouchements des images terribles
à plusieurs auteurs réaction je suis un
artiste il est mort et elle a beaucoup
qui meurt ok enfin vous pourriez au
moins qu'on patine je sais pas moi
encore n ont pas indiffèrent toute façon
je sais pas mais je veux je dis toi
quelle tristesse
tu vas soyez humain quoi on la refait
monsieur eddy mitchell est mort à 15
heures dommage parce qu'on appelle un
fan de la première heure je gemelli
mitchell à l'époque des chaussettes
noires surtout moins quinze membres elle
apporte sa disparition aujourd'hui c'est
c'est un drame pour vous dommage
c'est dommage c'est votre peine à votre
émotion monsieur merci beaucoup je vais
bien et moi un accident de chasse dans
ses toilettes un accident de poids des
charges dans ses toilettes
la compagnie johnnie walker a déjà perdu
quatre points en bourse
voilà je l'avoué j'y connais rien c'est
l'effet immédiat de la mort de di
michele qui était le plus gros
consommateur de johnny walker
ah bon c'est vrai il est mort qu'est ce
qui est arrivé comment s'est tiré une
balle dans l'anus aujourd'hui à 15h en
voyant les scores des ventes de patrick
bruel il n'a pas supporté les records
pour combattre dans l'anus au cerveau et
en désespoir de cause il s'est tiré une
balle dans la nuit
j'ai rien à vous lire eddy mitchell est
mort monsieur ça vous vous en foutez
j'aurais préféré que ce soit george
habache si concernant madame pas du trou
en ce qui concerne et démissionner si
vous n'êtes pas de mon avis la question
est réglée et à sery jean michael ça me
fait de la peine au dessus merci
monsieur aussi je n'ai pas de train oui
vous allez olla mais vous êtes bien
curieux à ses journalistes
monsieur alors vous vous adressiez un
officier de la légion d'honneur
un grand commandeur de la légion
d'honneur alors alors qu'il est s'il
vous plaît alphabet parce que moi aussi
j'ai des pin's cirque c'est pas dépit d'
moi c'est pas limpide mais il est
collector le vaudou les changes
je voulais échanges
histoire de stars
déjà tanné chronique et bizarrement les
gens aiment beaucoup ça mais non c'était
très drôle les gens bien marché
effectivement on leur dit le roi du
rock'n'roll est mort dans un premier
temps et 10 ha bon johnny après on dit
non non c est dit et les gens disent ah
vous me fait peur mais ça dans pas
compte mais c'est pas ça tape à côté de
faire ça non non tu me donnes tu me dis
si non non non c était mort de rire
s'intéresse beaucoup aux fils à papa il
en est lui-même peut-être points non on
va voir non merci
on
c'est un fils à papa avec toutes les
possibilités qu'il a pour réussir sa vie
toutes les ouvertures tout se passe bien
dès qu'il passe bien il est charmant
louis des charmants mais il manque de
dimension petit peu pas mal quand même
c'est pas mon genre je viens j'aime
plutôt son père vos protections perle
était meilleur journaliste meilleur
animateur mais un animateur c'est vrai
c'est un con comme son père peut pas
dire que ça me trouvais qu'il n'a pas de
talent drôle quand même il écrit bien
oui la même gueule que son père c'est
pas sa faute c'est pas critique ça on
peut avoir la même gueule que son père
est talentueux oui mais c'est pas son
cas lui à wasquehal mouais
et en plus et en plus si les frimeurs je
laime bras en fait il a le bon vivre
c'est gentil hein ça va aller à bientôt
un sport le sport
ils sont drôlement seibert ouais ils
sont du rhin oui je suis un peu triste
surtout son [ __ ]
oui oui des plus rien à dire il parlait
ce qui est on évite ces gens dans la rue
de mon père ouais mais il est mort tu
veux savoir de qui il parlait oui tu va
résister oui à la révélation c'était pas
de moi bon on regarde que pensez-vous du
fist au pied puis ça va pas chez vous du
fils de bernard tapie
c'est un con comme son père
voilà vous connaissez brigitte lahaie
brigitte la haie basse et la femme de
jean luc
jeanteur vous connaissez bronchite la
wii est une actrice une actrice une
actrice de film porno je crois quand
même faut gueuler il met trois poils et
et qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue
aujourd'hui aucune idée aucune idée ça
va pas bien brillant mais je sais pas
trop ça fait plus de télé la couche plus
j'en sais rien la dénommée soit un
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et aux
sports
non vous plaisantez pas du tout c'est
tombé ce matin vu comme va la france
savait tendre et guerre quoi c'est à
fait possible si connaît un score à
votre avis aux sports au lit ou au lit
elle doit connaître à ils sont les
marchés les matins elle vend des
poireaux sur les marchés aujourd'hui
vous le saviez
lors du tout ça vous étonne voilà
pourquoi ya pas de sot métier
non mais vous trouvez que c'est la suite
logique de ce qu'elle faisait avant
alors pas du tout parce qu'elle est
toujours dans le port aux barriques
aujourd'hui allait rentrer dans les
ordres à les religieuses dans un couvent
dans le lot et elle s'appelle soeur
brigitte semblable en costume de
religieuses ou qu'on sait quel point
vous donner encore des idées
alors oui certainement c'était quand
même dalle femmes
c'est une belle fille ça y'a pont il
m'est arrivé de rêver d'elle même
j'ai déjà palucher en regardant le k-7
de l'année n'ont jamais non vous savez
ce qu'elle est devenue aujourd'hui non
pas du tout non été nommé ce matin
ministre de la condition féminine
c'est super pourquoi pas après tout oui
c'est une [ __ ] enfin disons qu'à la fête
des films pornos à la vielle ministre
alors si vous la croisez demain vous
allez l'appeler madame la ministre ou
vieille [ __ ] purina la ministre enfin
pour ma part en ministre j'en ai depuis
ce matin non c'est pas possible
depuis ce matin ancien buteur avec
décennies comme ça non pas par conseil
des ministres non m'habiller c'est vrai
mais avec tout ce qu'elle a fait bon
juste suite à ça son passé et je crois
pas je pense pas yann dubois observé
l'étude de façon kiabi boire même tout
est le même chez elle
devenu ministre jeudi que possible c'est
serré des gosses qui a bu boira qui a vu
vous attentez à sa personne à elle parce
que ça subordonne tout un pack ursus de
carrière qui est pas sans arrière pensée
ce qui fait que vous êtes une bande de
pornographe et de dégueulasse vers 7
heures est facho merci beaucoup mais
voilà alors ça vous pouvez passer
merci infiniment
une chose est certaine c'est quand on
leur dit que tu as été nommé ministre de
la condition féminine ou quoi les gens
sont pas spécialement étonné tu vois
comme quoi notre époque quand même sous
qui a encore du pain sur la planche il
ya du pain sur la planche pour qu'ils le
croient tout ce qui était plus crédible
s'était mise de l'intérieur mais bon
tenez vous aimez dorothée tiens vous me
réglez madame s'il vous plaît pour
régler quoi que dise que c'est 30 francs
monsieur mais je ne vous ai rien demandé
non mais je sais bien c'est dorothée qui
a mis cette technique de vente au point
c'est de la vente directe et alors alors
on donnait dispose enfants et les
parents les tailles ensuite qu'à ma
chérie tu aimes dorothée cas c'est pour
toi
ces 33 madame cdh avant le direct a
maintenant mais pas le droit de
reprendre le disque à l'enfant dorothée
m'interdit de reprendre des disques que
j'ai donné et c'est dorothée boilard qui
a vu sa technique aux points
quoi dorothée lé pa petit c'est ce
qu'elle fait là c'est comme ça aux gens
on les met à main puis à dire après ces
trente francs mais c'est de recommencer
à dire c'est 30 francs merci c'est pour
moi vous donner
oui c'est une vente directe c'est
dorothée camille cette vente au point
pour se faire des couilles en or c'est
obligé vous l'avez tous chez madame j'ai
pas de monnaie je vous en donne 3g pas
de monnaie alors je vous donne un club
dorothée je veux te colle engins pin
saint jean un vibromasseur
qu'est ce que je fais le stérilet
dorothée qui va le sortir vous voulez
quoi qu'est ce que vous voulez aller
jouer sur l'autoroute les enfants
allaient à dorothée n'aime pas les
enfants alors foutez lui la paix à
dorothée un tiens c'est pour vous voilà
non c'est 30 francs madame vous me
réglez s'il vous plaît j'ai pas mal de
reprendre madame dorothée m'interdit de
reprendre les disques que je donne aux
enfants c'est pas bon pour son image
ces deux retraités a mis cette technique
aux points tiens ma chérie il faut que
maman dont vous êtes les chante avec vos
enfants
tu es mon chéri c'est pourquoi j'ai pas
mal de reprendre mon poème régler s'il
vous plaît mais plaignez-vous à dorothée
si vous n'êtes pas contente
regardez vous laisser aller la faire
pleurer les adhérents d'autres enfants
malheureux mais c'est dorothée qui a mis
ses principaux combats dorothée je
trouve ce que c'est débile en plus ce
n'est certes pas la pologne va parce que
ça rapporte du pognon c'est ça le
principal
elle est à deux doigts de pleurer c'est
moi qui te lèves rejeté l'offre
le père et de ma poche
alors laurent veux te dire la vérité
mais de dire la vérité je pensais à la
suite de cette séquence te demander de
venir s'excuser mais je pense que la
réaction de dorothée était quand même
beaucoup plus drôle et malin j'ai un
début d'érection bravo tout a été dit je
me mouille pas dans les sujets je crois
que dorothée eu la bonne réaction
c'est vrai on applaudit dorothée
vous connaissez ça c'est pas là comme à
cacher sa non-sélection hommage la donne
à la gauche
je suis pas là j'ai du mal à guy lange
et étrangers pendant de tous il appelle
un disque de chansons
oui on en débat c'est déjà on va vous
faire écouter les écouter je connais
j'attendais oui et c'était vous l'avez
entendu en entier le droit d'annoncer
passer sous la voie là vous allez voir
c'est passé suis la voix va quoi
jouir de la paix
wilson
12 heures mais jamais conseillé
pour l'activer
es tu
c'est bien c'est pas lui
vous trouvez ça se passait bien non
c'est ce que j'ose deux plus jeunes
parents
m
mais entre le type de conflit pour
remplacer martin sokouri de java c'est
plus pourri que de l'aja ça m'étonne de
lui c'est moi intérieur qui l'a fait roi
bestiaire je veux dire c'est malhonnête
de
la tromperie que les gens achetaient la
java bleue il avait la grosse [ __ ] à des
brigands alors dit oui ce que vous avez
à lui dire
je veux pas prendre position
il ya imposition chance ou de la route
138 lui il a pas raison de personnes
puis c'est tout
history seront dix ans qui prêtait
louise soucy et suffit d'agonie ce qu'il
a
il ya la robe un joli tube on peut
garder en santé doit tout du régisseur
sage et me connais pas très bien les
choses la voix fait pour la libye show
jean marc thibault enregistré dix ans
dépassait déjà bas mais en réalité ce
sont des chansons paillardes
oui mais moi j'adore ça tout ce qui est
un peu que je chante un message écrit à
petit aux riches vous raconter dans les
champs cultivés moi c'est que
il me faut que je suis arrivé tout ça le
problème
mais chaud c'est qu'il ya des personnes
âgées comme madame qui ont acheté ces
accords et qui ne savaient pas qui fâche
pourquoi pas
vas-y vas-y vas-y tu veux louer la
personne âgée mais sa nature aux
oreilles des clitoris rougissent fin et
tout c'est pas super 8 à 10
ça n'a pas sûr que les barbes d'accord
un vase il ya des gens âgés qui sont
mortes de malaise en écoutant la grosse
[ __ ] à dire grosse [ __ ] adultes évident
les revenus ils sont pas bien ces
mecs-là qu'il fallait devant lui les
gens ne continuent à danser sont les
grandes butane et du vin c'est sur un
combat n'est jamais rentré
mais cela
dans tout ça je mérite pas dans ces
eaux-là ce soft non mais les gens donc
finalement est persuadé qu'il chantait
des chansons de q1
oui j'en ai tellement pas plus que ça il
te crois capable de tout les gens pas
bishu sait bien que c'est pas un style
d'accord je suis effrayé par le clitoris
et à vue oui oui c'est pas combien fait
du mal à bischu
il s'est vengé ça va les manger c'est le
sens de sa vie il est découvert de
nouveaux horizons messieurs
tous
que pensez-vous de charlotte de
turckheim 1d charlotte de turckheim
connais pas cette comédienne japonais
pas à trouver comment physiquement
j'étais un bonhomme physiquement faut
vraiment se prononcer pas terrible
il est tiré plus moche quand même
peut-être plus moche ni rozic - elle est
pas belle mais est excitante
ah ouais elle est pas belle mais alors
allez oui ça vous dirait tremper votre
pinceau avec elle si j'ai beau lui
rendre service sympathique
elle a beaucoup de charme comme fille
comme elle est pas mal oui mais enfin
disons c'est pour moi c'est pas votre
genre c'est madame nettement mieux non
mais vraiment nul cette meuf a rien à
dire c'est ne pas jouer avec ghislaine
al anon à dormir dehors
honnêtement ces moments-là bourgeois sk
répressive autoritaire la fasch être moi
je peux pas quoi tu as khroub coin ouais
elle est mignonne elle a du charme pas
simplement pour regarder sur le plateau
et elle me dit qu'elle est très très
attiré par vous donc que lui répondez
vous
du gibier c'est pas et puis bombay je
veux c'est que ça pourra donner si
recevoir deux fois mais elle voudrait
faire l'amour en négo le mali dans le
casque mais il est d'accord ou pas
je ne souhaite pas aussi facilement
faire avec une femme
j'ai juste pour nick et elle me dit que
rappaz de sentiments du tout sédhiou
pouvoir parce que je suis mariée et puis
je m'engage et le lien souvent causé
saison d'aventuré les fans et sa tâche
normale si mince et entend donc même là
je suis j'ai envie de vous voir c'est
normal que si monsieur ati est cuit à
point
ce bâtiment la sécurité savent
accueillir des troupes dans mon village
à si elle jure de ne pas s'accrocher
est ce que vous seriez prêt lui faire
l'amour après toutes les photos ci
dessus quand même que l insécurité que
sa sécurité parce que c'est bagdad
elle voudrait savoir quel est votre
spécialité et comment oui c'est bien ça
comment s'appelle l'oncle de frédéric
mitterrand l'oncle je ne sais pas le nom
d'amy terran forcément mais se ressent
dont mitterrand allez-y c'est tout
mitterrand sur prénom je ne sais pas
l'oncle de frédéric mitterrand madame
l'oncle de frédéric mitterrand s'il ya
un piège autre histoire mais je n'y
touche pas monsieur comment s'appelle
longue de frédéric mitterrand et b selon
fo frédéric mitterrand choco qui sert
jamais non le jeune acteur
alors on dit quoi je vous dis je
disait je suis je serais tenter de vous
répondre françois mitterrand mais je
suis sûr que c'est pas ça fait quoi
je sais pas mais je sais c'est très
facile
ciao et e
on s'appelle françois mettant c'est le
président de la république mais vous
mêlez de l'ombre de messi mitterrand
sait pas qui est pareil du terrain
tu m'en veux pas me trilles lendemain fi
co star de star
qui sait
c'est alain chamfort
je le connais je le connais je le
connais je le connais je le connais ce
qui est arrivé aux enfants
niel
balavoine
je le connais ce petit ce petit jeune
jeu
du jeune mais ça c'est beaucoup plus
jeune mais il n'a pas tellement changé
oui savez qui c'est oui tu vois comment
il s'appelle un hasard boad à moi
non ce n'est pas ça dans
parce que se sont mises à l'eau
après après l'accident de voiture
demain les âges il a eu un accident de
voiture il ya six mois
six mois maintenant il est comme ça oh
la la
c'est surtout les
je veux bien mais c'est bien elle va
bien
on s'est trompé c'est via vous le
trouvez plus beau maintenant ou avant je
voulais faire ah bon les ducs cedeno
faut pas le dire
dites lui parce qu'il vous regarde et
lui adamo vous êtes très beau maintenant
comme ça des clés oui vous êtes autre
beau mâle tonneaux c'est bon science
merci adamo
derrière cherche je cherche je cherche
je cherche mon nom je n'ai pas tellement
les chanteurs moderne n'est pas moderne
madame il ya un gars c'est pas son nom
de star
oui mais j'arrive pas à le jeu je
l'avalé vous connaissez bien bien non
mais je t'écoute
j'ai un trou il ya le connaître alors
non non non j'ai vu à trouver
c'est papa
c'est ton papa st
ce papa
michel
jarry fut
coastal
et
j'ai posé une question et vous allez me
répondre
pas trop compliqué pour vous un bon
alors vous me dites que vous sortez du
film conversion la barre je vous dit que
c'est pas mal et où confession la barre
joie que surtout personne ne l'a vu le
temps que les gens sortent nous on aura
pas de lumière il va faire nuit de vous
dit que c'est pas mal et tout le monde
dit personne comme ça en fait le sujet
qu'est ce qu'on attend leno attention on
tourne mademoiselle vous sortez de quel
film confession d'un barjots avec avec
regardez moi regarder la caméra je pense
à rien
comédien mère chez oh c'est merveilleux
merveilleux alors ça vous a plu ou pas
c'est par ce qui se passe au début
rappelons le il tombe
du cheval
quelle est la salle cuzacq russe marqué
alors
quand tu couches
ils l'ont
lembras mois quand ils se battent
on va pas laisser dire ça at il dit ça
dérape on la refait donc alors embrassé
sur le film fais-toi qu'application n'a
pas du tout mais je vais le voir
justement ce matériel pour fêtes devant
la fiche
tu l'as pas vu encore on va faire comme
si tu l'avais vu tunisie juste deux mots
parce que nous après on a plus de
lumière on peut pas de tourner ok c'est
bien c'est comme ça qu'il sortait de la
ligne s'il te plaît dominique besnehard
bonjour vous sortez de quel film
confession d'un barjots alors vos
impressions qui veulent avorter un film
très original très avec un humour très
décapants et les sont vraiment étonnants
notamment anne brochet qui est
complètement contre emploi et non c'est
vraiment intéressant c'est le film
auquel vous vous attendiez en rentrant
c'est à dire que j'avais lu le scénario
c'est un peu mal mal placé donc quand on
lit un scénario où on a toujours une
idée sur le film et je trouve que la
forme est vraiment et la vraie
la pression c'est aussi des annales des
animaux comme dans son précédent film
ces deux personnes qui vous a le plus
marqué la scène où aller où
j'aime beaucoup la scène nous ou comment
il s'appelle
il polit t'arrive avec sa soeur qu'il
provoque et tout ça c'était une scène
vraiment bien joué les comédiens sont
114 mm 10 mois lors d un belge sans
brassard plus ce sont tous des alliés
les regardait tous ses amis je les
embrasse
néanmoins c'est à dire moi c'est
l'objectif saba c'est l'objectif
pascal
et
est ce que vous connaissez anémone la
comédienne à peine de non louis
j'appréciais la wii est à votre avis
elle a aidé d'avoir été la première dame
de france dans sa carrière pour faire du
cinéma danse pas est-ce que vous
l'appréciez c'est très cool cool
apprécié je n'aime pas les gens vulgaire
donc oui je sais la et de représentatif
de l'ensemble du
couches sociales enfin très répandu
finalement est-ce que celle là et
d'avoir été la maîtresse de valéry
giscard d'estaing pour démarrer sa
carrière à votre avis jilian totalement
ce genre de choses était mariée pendant
un an valéry giscard d'estaing et tire
et ça l'a propulsé est ce que ça vous
choque
mais ça ne m'intéresse pas je me sens à
des années lumière d'une personne pareil
nouvelle faute de goût le matin en vous
habillant pas du tout moi la femme d'un
président est tourné un film humain ça
me choque
anémone elle vous choque le sam est
chaud regarde aller sur le plateau dit
lui anémone a dit puisque vous en pensez
enfin ne sais pas anémone surpoids sur
le fait qu'elle ait fait des films nu
alors qu'elle était la première dame de
france
c'est la première dame de france à faire
des films nu ou nous en afrique vraiment
c'est choquant moi je ne commente pas
voilà c'est ce que j'ai à dire regardez
les photos de tous les moyens sont bons
pour accéder à la célébrité
voilà vous l'approuvez oui puisque voilà
maintenant ce n'est plus avec les russes
car distincts et elle est connue à la
grille tout à gagner
est ce que vous connaissez enrico macias
on va bien sûr ce serait malheureux
vous pouvez me citer au moins une de ses
chansons bon bah j'en connais plein
multichances tomber alors attendez avait
fait que ça provienne à l'idée l'a pas
leader enrico macias se connaît a
commencé à johnny hallyday on dit ah non
je n'y allais moi je n'aime pas je les
rassure il ya un combat siège de
l'entente dû chanter bien qu est ce qu
elle veut dire moi je les connais toutes
ses chansons mais non mais elles ne
viennent pas l'idée m stance validé
madame enrico macias oui je sais me
citer au moins une chanson d'enrico
macias et moi une chanson d'enrico
macias enfants de tous pays non alignés
je veux dire à l'idée est dans la tête
n'a pas l'idée madame enrico macias est
prêt et alto macias qu'est-ce qui
chantait enfants de tous pays par sa une
chanson
c'est stupide cupide qu'il n'y a pas une
idée comme ça pas l'idée madame enrico
macias est atteint et vous pouvez pas
invité mais d'après sur la voir ou non
par un vous y êtes
citez moi une chanson d'enrico macias
malades chez z je peux même vous ne
chantez mais je ne suis pas du tout dans
le coup là pourtant je sais moi une
chanson d'enrico réfléchir connaissez
pas à quoi j j non on n'a pas
déconner c'est tout je connais tout mais
je sais que le statut qui dérivent recul
quand même ça ne vient pas là incapable
de me citer une seule chanson du enfants
de taupe et que je n'ai pas rapide ses
chansons quand même c'est ridicule il
connaît tout début de tous pays se sont
nourries qu'on nous propose et coppet
nyon macias
enfin de tous pays voyons là j'en
connais des tas de temps fils y
associant dre commercial à bord des
navires
co star des stars
monsieur vous qu'il avait une tronche
des intellectuels qui a écrit ça san
antonio frédéric dard j'ai déjà lu de
san antonio
oui les temps à perdre dans ces
conneries oui vous aimez oui a dit oui
au regard des soldes avec shame ouais
mais moi j'ai lequel écrit sa sainteté
mieux ses formes sognu non j'ai écrit
deux livres
ce n'est pas sûr persuadé william qui
d'autre quand même non non j'ai pas dit
l'auteur s'appelle frédéric dard et
twitter c'est frédéric dard je n'ai
jamais eu à brodeur entre les doigts non
boscher
venez venez venez prenez le voisin non
si j'étais vous élisez qui ne mange pas
de pain elle a vu ses mains et niall
jolette alors je laissais café ma
propose de baisse comme en chaire aura
c'est pour ça que j'y fasse a donc pour
vous si la littérature de métal grande
littérature oui frédéric à art
excusez moi mais mes plans a redit sont
d'anciennes caves à peu très peu alors
les immuniser au hasard la beauté d'un
drap blanc de ton jardin touche à ton tu
pensais que ça restera dans les annales
de la littérature ce genre de bouquin à
vrai dire enfin sincèrement non laurent
baffie était allé voir les gens dans la
rue pour leur parler de françoise hardy
et l'astrologie est prête à tout à fait
tu m'entends mouchoirs je serre les
dents voilà laurent baffie
bonjour est ce que vous aimez françoise
hardy sur le plateau de double jeu ah je
regarde pas cette émission
quoi qu'il en soit les sur le plateau
maintenant elle ne chante plus abc
dommage parce que j'aimais bien ses
chansons sont toutes des choses et
consacrent exclusivement l'astrologie
est ce que vous voulez avoir une chance
à lui des plus rien parce que
son grand frère celle à arrêter donc à
la single exemple petit haut risque pour
demain oui j'ose hardy a fait ses
preuves pour l'astrologie elle dit pas
de métro pour demain raison bien
spécifiques
elle voit une catastrophe pour vous si
vous prenez le métro de moscou un
accident c'est pas guy badie du tout
scorpion ascendant scorpion comme alain
delon mais dit elle tiens je ne savais
pas ok oui allez vous dit que la
conjoncture est très noir pour demain du
pommeau de douche madame pardon envoyé
une minerve conseil demain d'aller voir
votre toubib qui arrivait une erreur de
diagnostic qui pourrait entraîner des
séquelles graves pour demain un pont
elle me dit qu'en ce moment vous avez le
mercure dans les bonus et c'est chaud
pour vous en ce moment là en amour yann
9,1 et qu'aime le calme plat ouais vous
aimeriez ont souvent des personnes n'est
absolument pas même le confirme c'est
pas demain que j'avais trouvé la preuve
de votre vie
elle vous dit que vous n'êtes pas à
l'abri des fautes de goût franck et
madame et me demande si vous vous
habillez parfois sous l'emprise de la
drogue
non pas du tout elle me dit qu'il est un
sacré de l'hérault un bon vous devez est
1 1
c'est vrai qu'on est un sacré que tard
également
ah bon vous avez beaucoup les femmes
bah oui on peut pas vous n'êtes pas
toujours d'une honnêteté que j'en pleure
avec elle ah bon tiens mais des
aventures en ce moment le rendre aux
professionnels pas spécialement
elle comprend que vous pouvez pas parler
elle veut elle me dit vous diack
ça va aller en s'arrangeant pour ce que
vous savez bon vous êtes petit point de
parfois deux
dejean avait des petits problèmes
gastriques pas du tout bon foulée un peu
du goulot moi je sais pas je vois pas
des docteurs depuis 30 ans évitez le
karaté la moto la moto oui éviter la
moto c'est ouais ouais ouais sa place le
deltaplane ou ils me voulaient régler je
peux passer de chantrans pour
l'horoscope de par des passants payé
puisqu'il s'en prend basse et françoise
hardy comment vous portez sont payés
alors ils me l'avaient pas demandée
excusez moi vous permettez à bien vous
permettra non merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de la
latitude
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu